there was really no option back then
though it was like you you were out
promoting something it's what you did
that's what the studio wanted you to do
joining rachel bilson on her broad ideas
podcast 39 year old canadian actress
alicia cuthbert recalls feeling
pressured by studio execs early in her
career to pose in hyper-sexualized men's
magazines but she reveals these types of
shoots were commonplace for many
actresses back then i think we just we
kind of ended up in a space at that time
where that was really sort of happening
and yeah i mean halle berry was doing it
for god's sake it was very of the moment
it was jennifer aniston was doing it
topping several hot lists over the years
including being named tv's most
beautiful woman by maxim in 2013. the
girl next door star shares how she
struggles to see these stories and
images circulate online when someone
reads my bio
those things come up where
they actually don't mean anything in
regards to me as a person or my career
and i don't even know like those lists
are not even it's it's not like it's
like i won an olympic medal like it's
just like it was some list some random
magazine decided to create now a mother
cuthbert says she hopes to use her
experiences to educate her two young
children about the importance of
self-love if i could take what i know
now about you know having two children
and going back to i would be so much
kinder to myself
and not that i had any sort of you know
i i luckily i didn't have any eating
issues or anything like that but i i
definitely
like you know got caught up in that
wanting to
like you said wanting to live up to what
everyone was expecting of us which was
to be the hottest woman in the world
i'm an actress